I don't think fundamentally anything has
changed in the way you know America is
towards new businesses and it's it's a
great place to run and start a business
that's for sure eyes I think it's going
to stay the same for a long time and
that is around the talent around a lot
of things at the Capitol and the market
size and everything is that comes with
it however what we've seen in the past
week is the huge amount of uncertainty
that was what would cause based on a
very swift and swift action that didn't
have any great period and that is
something that makes you think twice
before you make the next move whether
it's the same country or you know hiring
the next person that requires a
sponsorship for visa or fundamentally
and sadly it might force some people to
think about your place of birth when
they want to hire you because although
it's not legal and but we've seen that
the potential of being you being
discriminated when it comes to traveling
abroad whether it's the business trade
show or a seminar is high and if these
disruptions are going to be something
uncertain that the businesses cannot
predict I would imagine that some
employers won't think twice before their
one higher British national was born in
Iran Iraq or Somalia you disappointed
that Theresa May hasn't made more of a
stand against Donald Trump for this I
felt that I'd her mr. is trying to cater
too much for the current administration
in the hope that probably she gets a
trade deal that's badly needed as a
result of breaks it but um that kind of
made her response very weak and meek
what would you like to see the rest of
the tech sector doing the likes of
Google and Facebook do you think these
companies should be making a stand
against mr. Trump on this issue I
understand the I understand the
predicament that the company has when it
comes to a particle issue usually
companies don't want to avoid that and I
think that's the right thing to do for
many businesses um and I think while I
think a larger company should get
involved in this I don't think it should
be at the political level I think it's a
very practical of elevating it could
help a lot of smaller businesses
frankly applying for a for an h1 visa or
sponsorship even in the UK is a costly
and very common same process that needs
to needs to go companies need to spend
time on and hire people for now if the
small business like ours is affected by
this that is proportionately I can
completely imagine that are more
companies that are completely affected
the same way the problem is you know
confronting something like a
presidential executive order in a
federal court it's a very costly and
specific business week we cannot afford
so what happens is we district of a
stroke stroke of a pen um we do these
employees that cannot come back to work
but companies like Apple like Google
like Facebook I'm sure they have
sponsored a lot of other employees of
their employees from those affected
countries I would imagine they would
have to challenge this on the basis of
work visas at least or green card
holders just change them since but at
these work permit holders to come back
to work and it will challenge and I
think depending on how they approach it
legally it might open up some precedent
legal precedent for smaller companies
like us who cannot confront who cannot
afford to go to court and pd pay the
legal fees will open up the way for us
to bring our people back to work and
economic businesses what would you say
to Donald Trump if you could speak to
him personally I think that's a that's a
difficult question I think I think this
could have been handled in much smoother
way with with a lot of thought and
communication and um a lot of things
that could have been couldn't had people
could have prepared people in the way
that they would then know what to do and
I think there was a lot of things that
could have could have been thought
through but I think that didn't happen
and that's um that's disappointing part
from from president that's very business
friendly